da kommen wir zu einem etwas leichteren
thema aber dennoch einem sehr ernsten
wie ich finde und zwar dem wahlkampf und
ich würde sagen dass der schmutzigste
wahlkampf aktuell geführt wird gegen
armin laschet es war viel die rede davon
gegen die schlimmer über die schlimme
angriffe gegen frau berbalk es kamen
sofort der vorwurf des sexismus an der
rechten hetzkampagne als es um ihr buch
ging nur ehrlich gesagt ich erinner mich
damals nicht dass die konservativen und
die liberalen so drauf gehauen haben wir
jetzt auf armin laschet draufgehauen
wird und da ist einfach jedes mittel
recht also das schickt man auch
aktivisten in talkshows und niemand hat
ein problem damit dabei haben im mai die
grünen und die spd noch feierlich
erklärung unterschrieben dass man achtet
dass man einen fairen wahlkampf machen
will dass man den gegner nicht
persönlich angreift und aus armin
laschet der wirklich keinen tollen
wahlkampf macht und man muss ihn auch
nicht mögen und nicht wählen wollen aber
er wird gerade verteufelt als wäre er
mindestens der nächste donald trump als
er will das klima kehlen er will aus
deutschen und eine fundamental religiöse
republik machen sein berater tanne in
dem minsky ist sowieso ein absoluter
fassung mitglied einer einer homophoben
sekte also da wird so viel rausgeholt
gegen ihn dass man gegen andere
kandidaten überhaupt nicht findet klar
die cdu selbst kann vielleicht nicht so
gut mobilisieren die linken man schon
immer besser darin aber ich finde da
geht gerade einfach anstand verloren und
das ist gefährlich für deutschland süße
these von dir philipp wenn die cdu so
tief gesunken ist dann klasse dass sie
jetzt schon dein mitleid braucht das
sage ich das wäre söder nicht passiert
dass du hier bei viertel nach acht sitzt
und mitleid mit dem spitzenkandidaten
markus söder hass und sagt das ist ja
ganz unfair wir da von grünen und linken
und der spd so persönlich angegangen
wird das wäre markus söder nicht
passierte hätte halt einfach
zurückgekauft wackelte da werden ganz
andere sachen im wahlkampf passiert aber
dass er jetzt nicht da
wären zum beispiel die spitzeleien
wieder schritt würde nicht so ins zeug
ich kann mir lebhaft einiges vorstellen
ich finde es eine piaf in der diagnose
recht hat und das ist auch typisch ist
dass man gegen gegen weiße männer kann
man halt auch viel mehr auszahlen als
gegen weiße frauen und insofern dass das
das stimmt schon ich hoffe dass jetzt
alle die das nicht allzusehr erstens ist
man es gewohnt als cdu politikerin dass
bei einem ganz andere maßstäbe angelegt
und ich finde dass armin laschet
wirklich es wirklich extrem souveränen
damit umgeht gerade auftritt gestern mit
der aktivistin die sich da vorher auf
twitter gefreut hat dass sie ihn jetzt
was fahrzeugen klein machen will oder
irgendwann so eine vollwertige fertig
machen will das habe ja so gut gekonnte
dass sie sogar am ende lang vollständig
hat wir brauchen hier mit leute
vielleicht sogar er braucht ihr mitleid
gar nicht der armin laschet ja ja ich
muss in erwägung muss schrieb ein buch
vor jahren mit dem titel wie man
fanatiker kuriert und seine antwort war
man kann mit fanatiker gar nicht
diskutieren man kann sie nicht kurieren
und ich sage dir jemand der in einer
diskussion geht weil er jemand ihn
fertig machen will es nicht offen für
argumente und diese diskussion kann
armin laschet und kunden andere nicht
gewinnen wir haben eine klimakrise wir
müssen mehr tun aber diese
apokalyptische vorstellungen dass die
welt ein paar jahren untergeht und das
ist die letzte generation die noch
irgendwas machen kann das ist mir zu
heftig dass es mir zu apokalyptisch und
es wäre gut nicht nur für den wahlkampf
sondern auch für die klima dass man ein
bisschen nüchtern wege sucht dass wir
unsere planeten retten aber ohne dass
wir auch unsere wohlstand dann verlieren
und ich glaube auf dieser ebene haben
wir die diskurse bis jetzt vor allem in
diesem wahlkampf nicht wirklich geführt
aber wir reden darüber philips these der
sagt 'mensch der ami lasche der wird
verteufelt hier ging es ja jetzt nicht
nur um diesen wahrhaft missglückten
versuch der von der ard eine
konfrontation herzustellen aber es geht
um angebliche verteufelung im wahlkampf
das muss man doch halt einfach aushalten
im wahlkampf wir streiken das ist der
größte der spannendste wahlkampf seit 16
jahren man da können wir doch nicht so
ein dünnes fell habe ich würde sehr
gerne hören was viele ander als profi
dazu sagt aber einmal noch meine these
wie geht es nicht darum dass ich mitleid
mit armin laschet habe aber ich glaube
das ist einfach eine ein wahlkampf der
spuren hinterlassen wird und er wird nun
mal in so einer heftigkeit nur von einer
seite geführt und wenn wir tatsächlich
jetzt ein fast schon rechtsextremen
homophoben klimaleugner als cdu oder
unionskandidat hätten bitte schön aber
armin laschet wird gerade so fertig
gemacht wird so eine wortwahl gewählt da
fehlen mir die worte wenn wir mal was
passiert wenn wirklich mal ein schlimmer
typ kommt dann kann man ja nichts mehr
sagen und ich glaube wir werden uns
danach nicht mehr in die augen schauen
können man muss immer genau gucken wo
diese worte gefunden werden in sozialen
netzwerken dann geht es natürlich anders
zur sache als in der allgemeinen
berichterstattung weil das problem von
armin laschet ist auch ein ganz anderes
der macht auch gar keinen wahlkampf ich
habe heute gesehen dafür nicht nur
hubschrauber von a nach b nach c das ist
dann eine tolle geschichte weil
hubschrauber ist irgendwas mit ferrari
habe ich nicht ganz verstanden aber auf
jeden fall ist er unterwegs aber er hat
kein thema er hat überhaupt kein thema
irgendwie was mit vertrauen und ja
wirtschaft aber hätte sich hingestellt
gesagt mit mir gibt es keine steuerung
das sage ich euch das verspreche ich
euch meine irgendetwas andere die spd
die chance hat dir genau zwölf ich meine
ich referiere das ist auch zwölf euro
mindestlohn er sagt mit mir sie kennen
mich nicht er sagt reicht offenbar um
ihnen vier bis fünf prozentpunkte über
armin laschet zu setzen etwas was vor
drei monaten noch nie jemand für möglich
gehalten hat danach die cdu vor fünf
monaten bei 40% jetzt schlechtestes
ergebnis der nachkriegsgeschichte waren
die letzten bundestagswahl mit knapp 33
prozent jetzt liegen die elf
prozentpunkte darunter also da muss ja
irgendwas passiert sein und irgendwo gab
es doch diesen moment das kann man nicht
regieren als armin laschet in der flut
stand deutschland war gerade dabei sich
ein bild von ihm zu machen kann der das
kann das nicht und da hat er versagt
nicht nur einmal nicht nur zweimal hatte
diese schrei momente als angeschrieben
wurde wieder schlecht reagiert hat er
hatte dieses was auch immer gefällt oder
nicht gepflegte bild von demjenigen der
ihm gegenüberstand und der sich nass
regnen lassen musste während er
geschützt vom personenschützer das dann
mit dem schirm und er hatte natürlich
das lachen wofür sich da ein paar mal
entschuldigt hat aber auch so eine
nummer was wir da gerade gesehen haben
diese geschichte mit den kindern im zelt
meine güte wenn ich sehe dass dem knopf
im ohr haben dann sage ich doch nehmen
sie den mal raus vielleicht doch neben
sie raus weil das ist doch klar warum
setze ich mich in eine skripte sendung
mit kindern wo die kinder noch irgendwas
aus uhr kriegen und da braucht man eine
olaf scholz
da braucht man die souveränität zu sagen
das mache ich nicht mit freunde machen
dass sie anders und die souveränität
city und das merken die menschen
deswegen steht er da wo ist also ich
finde wenn man armin laschet in diesem
wahlkampf eines nun wirklich nicht
erkennen kann dann ist das souveränität
und starke nerven ich finde jetzt gerade
seine auftritte in den dreh in den
beiträgen waren
extrem souverän selbst
bei anderes das stimmt ja so nicht ganz
nachdem zuvor dem zweiten teil wurden
die menschen gefragt wer ihr favorit ist
nach dem zweiten trailer und da hat an
armin laschet 9 prozentpunkte bei dimap
zugelegt und oder scholz 9 prozentpunkte
verloren also das ist ja nur ja oder
scheiß liegt noch vorne will ich ja
gerne zu stehen aber da dreht sich im
moment was ich glaube dass das ein ganz
knappes ergebnis wird und dass die
umfragen der im moment nicht die
realität widerspiegeln ich glaube dass
olaf scholz einfach ein großes glück hat
die skandale die ihr nun offenkundig zu
verantworten hat die die haben das
problem dass 90 prozent der menschen sie
nicht verstehen wer weiß wer kann schon
genau definieren worum es bei comics
geht also wird er oft abgeschaltet da
hat er glück gehabt und lachen in der
umfassenden situation ich sag auch
menschlich das versteht man sehr viel
besser während der marke sony passiert
wäre ein gerd schröder nicht passiert
wäre auch einem edmund stoiber nicht
passiert wäre angela merkel nicht
passiert und klar er hat sich der
pension ich will das auch nicht so hoch
hängt es aber ist es halt so ist es halt
so eine geschichte die wehren manchen
menschen nicht passiert und da muss man
sich dann daran messen lassen und das
sind es sind ja es gibt mir ja gar nicht
um den moment ich will das gar nicht
verteufeln ich sage nur so als quasi
beobachter es gibt momente die
wahlkämpfe definieren es gab eine
fernsehdebatte zwischen george bush
senior ewig her 92 glaube ich bill
clinton da hat bush einmal auf die uhr
geguckt während der debatte das war der
freezing moment dieser debatte
verschieden genervt unter druck hat im
wesentlichen sinne diese wahl gegen ihn
entschied und solche momente gibt es und
so einen moment war das lachen weil es
mehr ausdruckt in diesem moment also so
pessimistisch bin ich da nicht so weit
ich weiß hat er ja auch gesagt dass er
überhaupt nicht gehört hat er war weit
so weit weg dass eher steinmeier ja gar
nicht verstanden auch die ja keine frage
das ist ja schon wichtig ich würde auch
sagen angela merkel vor allen dingen
wäre es halt nicht passiert man hat den
direkten vergleich man hat auch angela
merkel in den flutgebieten gesehen und
ja das war heute am ihnen das haben wir
armin laschet ist ist er ist der
wahrscheinlich der menschlichere der
persönlichere typ und ich finde genau
das wird auch in seinen auftritten
deutlich gerade wenn er mit anfragen
konfrontiert wird das sind keine stand
sind die da kommen sondern da geht er
extrem menschlich persönlich zugewandt
auf einem gerade das wünsche ich mir von
dem kanzler aber sie haben ja die
amerikanische verhältnisse hier
dargestellt und ich frage mich ob wir
auch in diese richtung gehen das ist
viel weniger dann um ihn halt geht und
um bilder und ich würde diese wahlkampf
als der wahlkampf der bilder eigentlich
darstellen und das macht mir schon
sorgen ich hätte gerne einen ganz
anderen weg geschlagen sind den usa wo
jeder bewegung jeder
hemmt den mann trägt eigentlich auch
entscheidend sein kann und für die
themen müssten halt die politiker sorgen
vor allen dingen man die sind haushalte
spitzenkandidat die themen setzen wir
hüpfen kurz in die werbung und sind in
wenigen minuten hier zurück bei viertel
[Musik]